[Music]
sarah's in spokane
hey sarah welcome to the dave ramsey
show
good afternoon thanks for taking my call
um the reason i'm calling is my husband
and i
need some help um my father-in-law is
trying to convince
my mom my mother-in-law to close out
her inherited ira because he's convinced
that the stock market is going to crash
so i want to know is how can i convince
them to keep the money in the ira or
should i have them move it so
it's hard to have it's hard to convince
anyone who is suffering from political
paranoia
to do anything because he's bought off
he's bought off on the idea that
joe biden is the end of the world
right and um you know every president
that has been elected since i've been an
adult was going to bring about the end
of the world by the people that didn't
vote for him and none of them did
you know i i you're yeah i totally agree
i don't i don't know i mean how you
gonna get in his head i don't know i
mean
he he is he needs to turn off fox news
is what he needs to do
and turn off cnn and quit looking on
these stupid but websites
because there's no historical data
anywhere
to indicate that a single party
no matter how crooked or incompetent a
president is
has the power to destroy america
there's no data i mean there's no
there's no time in history
no matter you can find the worst
possible presidency
in history and you can argue about what
that is and the stock market did okay
yeah so he's wrong he's wrong
you know we could we could talk about
whether we agree with
the fact that he hates joe biden or
whether we agree with
you know he went down a trump rabbit
hole of some kind we could talk about
all that as a separate subject if you
want but that's not a point
the point is i regardless of whether i
agree with all the crap they're doing up
there
i've never agreed with all the crap any
of them have done up there but i keep
investing and i've always invested
because the
data says the historical data on the
stock market says
no matter what [ __ ] is in the white
house we
still seem to be able to make money in
the dadgum
stock market right
that's that's the only thing i could
tell that there's something
that's what i keep yeah i would just say
dad there is no
nothing to indicate that your paranoia
is accurate
okay and you're gonna you're gonna lose
a lot of money
let me give you another example okay how
about this one covid
is going to bring the economy to its
knees and it will never get up
you remember that one i do and the stock
market
dove way down
in march and april remember i do
you know what it made last year almost
16
rate of return from january to january
[Applause]
and that's in the middle of freaking
covet trying to destroy our lives it
made 16
last year so if you freaked out if you
had to covet freak out and pulled all
your money on the market
you missed 16 on your money
wow this is the dave ramsey show